welcome back to the afternoon session
you may already know but we are
discovering new cases of covert among
the participants every day so on behalf
of Simons I strongly encourage everyone
to buy masks especially if being exposed
uh between close proximity of people who
have tested positive I have masks here
for anyone who
gestures okay thank you let me know if
you want one
yes of course
and also get tested if you need
collector
tests yeah that's right they have tests
available you have to tell them you're a
speaker or something
[Music]
okay and now it's my pleasure to have
Suraj who graduated from Stanford a few
years ago and now is an assistant
professor of Economics at Cornell to
talk about learning through the grade
point
thanks me so thanks everyone for joining
today and and special thanks to the
organizers for inviting me to this very
nice conference uh and bringing together
such an Eclectic group of researchers
um it's been a lot of fun today I'm
going to present uh joint work with Matt
Jackson and David McAdams and the title
of this paper is learning through the
grapevine the impact of noise and the
breadth and depth of social networks
this is a paper about that tries to
think about misinformation and some
simple tools that we can we might use to
combat it and uh to frame our main
question I'm going to show you a couple
of quotes
so here's a quote by uh Senator
Elizabeth Warren she says the safety of
our democracy is more important than
shareholder dividends and CEO salaries
and we need tech companies to behave
accordingly
that's why I'm calling on them to take
real steps right now to fight this
information
however Mark Zuckerberg disagrees with
this point and says I don't think that
Facebook or Internet Platforms in
general should be our bitters of Truth
this exchange
um sort of highlights uh one of the main
tensions that arises when we think about
using uh traditional tools like
censorship and fact checking to combat
misinformation
and that tension is that at the end of
the day we have to appoint somebody to
be an Arbiter of Truth someone who's
going to do the censoring and fact
checking for us and there's no easy
answers as to who's uh the right person
for the job
on the one hand we might worry about
giving governments this power uh we
might worry they encroach on our freedom
of speech or use this power towards
various political ends
on the other hand we can't rely really
on platforms to properly regulate
themselves they might have incentives to
appear as neutral channels so as not to
alienate certain groups of users who
might perceive them as being guides
particularly these issues of of bias
also come up to some extent when you
rely on things like crowdsourced fact
check
now even if you were to go ahead and and
censorship in fact checking there are
other limitations so first of all
there's a huge volume of Communication
online you can't hope to cover all of it
or even even a majority of it
you might rely on various algorithms to
help you do this but algorithms have
trouble with things like satire and
humor so they might not be able to tell
what's true and what was just a joke
and finally there are some channels of
communications which are meant to be
private and these are encrypted channels
like WhatsApp or or communication over
other messaging platforms and so here we
can't even observe the content that's
being sent around so we can't actually
rely on these tools so that's the
limitations
so in light of all of these observations
we ask the following question in this
paper is how do we promote truth without
actually taking a stance on what's true
or what's false and without actually
even observing uh the content of the
messages that are being sent out
so uh the plan in this talk is to do the
following first I'll show you a very
simple and stylized model of noisy
communication on networks and then a
model of how nodes react to the
information that they hear from their
Networks
and then we'll turn to looking at
neutral policies that reduce
misinformation without relying on uh the
policy makers prior about the true state
or without relying on the policy maker
actually having to observe the messages
that are being sent
all right so let's start with the model
noise you can make
before I get into the model I'm going to
show you just a few stories to kind of
motivate the the way we think about
things so Simmons adamic and Adar in
this 2011 paper give an interesting
account of a series of tweets that were
posted so initially someone writes uh
street style shooting in Oxford Circus
for Asos and Diet Coke let me know if
you're around
this quickly became retweeted with the
additional message shooting in progress
in Oxford Circus what
which then got picked up by someone who
wrote a lot more definitively shooting
in progress in Oxford Circus stay safe
all within three so a series of what
seemed to be uh misunderstandings uh led
to the spread of some false information
of course sometimes misinformation can
be spread more deliberately so here's
one such account
the Yellowstone volcano Observatory
wrote an article about the repairs that
they did for a monitoring station that
was damaged during some storm
very quickly a tabloid wrote an article
about this basically really exaggerating
the truth and claimed that Yellowstone
was not monitored
and uh in fact they did a really poor
job of of uh reading the contents of the
the the original article
um so some words like borehole became
Boreal uh and so the messages really got
uh uh mixed up
and it turned out that this misspelling
of of borehole persisted uh and and the
same misinformation that was that was uh
written up in the Tabloid persisted in
future social media reports that picked
up on that article
so here we have a mix of some deliberate
mutations along with some some uh uh
random errors as well
the one question you might ask is what's
the Frequency with which these kinds of
things happen maybe one way of answering
it is through introspection you you
think how many how often do these types
of miscommunication arise in your own uh
day-to-day lives
um there's also some evidence to suggest
that in online communication these these
numbers aren't small uh so academic at
all in 2016
um have basically showed uh that uh a
variety of viral memes had pretty high
mutation rates and and a lot of variants
so one meme was reposted 470 000 times
with an 11 mutation rate and it ended up
having over a hundred thousand variants
okay and this wasn't uncommon in their
data set
now this kind of thing need not happen
only in online communication
um so uh another piece of evidence is
that there are over 500 000 textual
variants of the Greek New Testament not
including spelling errors so these are
substantive changes to meanings of
various passages and so these kinds of
errors in communication are are pretty
prevalent it seems
so this is going to motivate us to try
to write down a model that captures
noisy transmission in a setting where
messages are sequentially relayed okay
so this isn't a model of of Twitter or
anything like that but to give a more
concrete example you might think of a
messaging platform like WhatsApp
and sort of private communication
between individuals
so here's a model
I'm going to think about a state of the
world Omega which is either one or two
okay so uh you can think of this as
encoding
um climate change is real or climate
change isn't real uh this diet will be
helpful for to to lose weight or it
won't be helpful you can also think
about states that are messages that
aren't too far apart so I think about
one message being
um this medication or vaccine has no
side effects and another message uh
being that side effects are very very
rare
and there's a probability Theta that the
state of the world is one
agents here IID binary signals about the
state with some probability are
and they're initially uninformed with
probability one minus r
okay and then noisily messages are going
to get relayed uh to uh the agent's
Neighbors in this network
I'm going to tell you what what noise
looks like and what what the network
looks like
so there's a probability uh mu sub zero
one and a probability mu sub 1 0 both
less than one half of messages mutating
and transmission mu Sub 0 1 is the
probability that a zero message that I
uh have gets mutated into one message
when I pass it to the next person mu sub
1 0 is the probability that a one
message gets mutated into a zero
messenger transmission
and these mutations are going to be IID
at each step of communication
and they can be right you can think of
them as being random or delivered so one
thing here is that the agents aren't
strategic okay so here at the end of the
day people are making some choices those
are going to result in certain
probabilities of messages being right or
wrong that's not to say that incentives
aren't important I'm I'm an economist
and so are my co-author so we will uh
never you'll never catch us saying that
it's just that here in these sort of
settings we don't really there might be
a variety of reasons why why people are
actually sending various messages we
want to focus on just sort of the N
error probabilities that these things
generate and the probabilities of
transmission and work with that and see
what we could say in this sort of model
without incentives alone
probably
um so so all I mean by that is there
might be certain agents in the network
who uh are more prone to saying one sort
of message than the other and uh so they
and their location itself might be
random Network and so in that sense uh
it can be captured by these
probabilities
is
full
deliberate means that actually I trust
so we think of things that from a sort
of X anti perspective at every step of
communication these are the
probabilities that of mutation failures
um but there could be certain agents who
are for example going to say
um that the message is one even if they
hear a zero
um and and vice versa and those kind of
Agents might occur in the network with
some probability and so we're capturing
from from an x-ente perspective there
are just certain probabilities that that
these kinds of mutations happen at every
step of communication based on the
identity of the individuals who are
passing it and just the noise inherent
in the transmission process thank you
sorry it doesn't matter your
sort of
outside
delicious which ones I thought if you
flip it while you do the same thing then
you just end up at the same one that's
what it is so it could be random but you
never trust me these are two different
interpret it this is this is
yep
now uh so this is one type of noise the
content of message is changing another
type of noises that there might be
transmission failures so uh I tell I
mean something but he doesn't think that
it's important enough to relay to kids
end so you might drop the message
um uh so there can be probabilities P
sub one of passing a message of type one
and probability piece of zero passing a
message of type zero
um and of course in general these piece
of ones and P Sub Zeros might be
different so uh you might be more likely
to pass along a message if you're
reporting uh if you're telling a funnier
joke or you're reporting news or or uh
saying something that has a as a sort of
statistically significant result we're
passing along a more salacious rumor so
the the actual content of the message
can of course affect its transmission
probabilities but in in today's talk I'm
going to abstract away from that and
just assume that there's some constant
probability of messages being dropped at
every single
foreign
so I still haven't told you what the
network looks like but before I get to
that let me describe what a chain of
message passing uh is going to look like
okay so there's some initial Source who
got some signal about the state of the
world in this passing this along and
ultimately there's some and receiver who
I'll call the learner who observes Some
Noise up version this uh initial message
right and the process
yeah and so the process was something
like this suppose initially that uh the
uh Source observes a signal of type 1.
this uh message uh survives and doesn't
mutate with some probability and so it's
going to be transmitted as a one message
but some probability it survives but
mutates uh gets transmitted as a zero
message and with some probability it's
going to be dropped entirely
and if it does get uh transmitted as a
one message again this process repeats
but this other note
foreign
so we haven't said anything about how
nodes are processing the information uh
yet and uh in fact the agents here won't
be patient so I'll I'll get to that but
right now all that's happening is
mechanically a message that started with
the first agent is getting passed along
in a potentially noised up way and so
this game of telephone is being played
no and it may be that the second node
also got its own signal which it is also
transmitting that that might also be
happening but we're just talking about
so far the message that originated with
the very first note oh so I learned
to observe the message and you you in
fact here you won't actually know uh
where it came from uh but you you'll
observe some and I know your models have
to think of one source awesome sort of
messages
it will it will get corrupted and so so
here I'm just I'm just uh charting out
the life cycle of a message that
originated with the node in the very
left but in general things will get
corrupted though in the way that that
you're imagining um so after I show you
this message passing along the chain
where I'm charting on the life cycle of
a single message I'll show you the
actual Network and a bunch of different
messages originating at different points
that are coming in potentially getting
corrupted
so uh you know here things got
Faithfully transmitted in the first step
and the process is repeating itself
alternatively the one message might get
corrupted into a zero message and now
there's different probabilities of the
zero message mutating back into a one uh
staying as a zero
and it might be possible that the
message actually just gets dropped in
this first step of communication and in
that case then there's nothing else
okay so this process repeats itself and
uh just as you anticipated we now have
now has Mark all chain that describes
the state uh that a message is taking on
at any step in communication right even
with this transition Matrix
um and in particular you can see that
being dropped is an absorbing state so
once the message is dropped it remains
dropped
right
okay okay so now let me get to the
network
so
for each node we're going to consider
the information sources of that code
these are the people who send you things
these are my uncles who send me
information on WhatsApp
they have their own sources who they
talk to and so on
and so I'm going to assume that my
information Network
my direct sources their direct sources
and so on is a directed tree where the
expected number of parents were node is
D okay so I'm going to assume away
Cycles uh just because it sort of
complicates the analysis without
actually changing much the the nature of
our main results
thank you
and the learner you can think of as the
root of this tree and so this is the
picture
um that you should have in mind so the
learner is down here
he has three parent nodes
initially some nodes received a signal
about the state of the world
that most of them heard one signals uh
one node heard a zero signal
this then gets passed along
to certain levels in this agents
here you can see that there was a
transmission failure the message got
dropped the other messages got passed
along successfully
they they pass along another step here
there was a message mutation so the one
turned into a zero
so you're assuming each person only
sends the message to maximum one other
person nope so they could be sending it
to other people but I'm only interested
in this learner's information
in principle that note could talk to
poor people and then you have different
paths yeah so here I'm assuming a
tree-like structure but this node might
also be communicating to other people
who are not in this learner's
information
so you might be telling friends who I
have no contact with and so I don't
actually care what happens
um to what's said to those those because
that information is never going to come
back but I am assuming that a tree like
structure so there are multiple paths
for these this information
so the tree is from the perspective of
each learner but like yeah Union of all
these trees multiple people can be
sending multiple messages
uh because if I start to send to various
people you don't even know who is
supposed to learn or at the end yeah
teacher how to avoid that for some
Learners in the network to get
absolutely so so the
um so you wanted points as well such any
node sees only according to it
so I'm abstracting away from those
concerns so the top notes for example
they never get to learn anything because
[Music]
[Music]
how do I synthesize the two you you so
so this is a crucial aspect of this
model there are models of communication
where you learn from uh your network you
form some posterior belief to say and
then you send this synthesized message
this is not that this is we're passing
along physical messages
and we will pass on each of those
messages with some confidence
and so we're not doing any any questions
this learner at the bottom bill in
general received many messages deep
along the same house exactly receive
several messages Etc yeah
in fact yeah it's probably a good idea
to add such an instance but yeah that is
totally important
so here uh once this process concluded
the uh learner ended up to receiving
three messages one of fortresses that
your portugals
so that's the model of communication
now I'm going to talk about how we think
about the way nodes react to this
information
so I'm going to Define this quantity M
to be 1 minus the sum of these mutation
rates
and these are just simple computations
which reflect the probability of seeing
a Zero versus the probability of seeing
a one from a message that originated T
steps away when the state is zero
and this is the probability of seeing a
one versus zero when the state is one
um what you'll notice is so this T
should be in the exponent what you'll
notice is that as t uh grows large and
so these messages originating really
really far away from me
both these quantities are going to
converge to just the ratio of of
mutation rates
right so whether or not I hear a one
message or a zero message from a node
that's really far away is really only
going to depend on what's the propensity
of one message is to turn into zero
messages and vice versa
foreign
this is not our model so this is a model
and a companion paper but let's just
think about it for a second so suppose
that uh the learner actually knows these
mutation rates and knows the distances
that message has traveled right so
messages get tagged with information
about the source and you know how far
they traveled before they got to you
if the learner is Bayesian and he's
going to use differences in these
frequency ratios to form some posterior
and more signals meaning broader and
deeper information networks is going to
unambiguously mean more learning for the
agent
but reality is is more more complicated
um first uh this T may be unknown
so messages might not come tagged with
information about where they were
sourced from and in this case we have
the sort of corruption that you're
talking about where I don't know if this
is a high quality piece of information
because it you know didn't have many
chances to get noised up or whether
whether it's low quality because it's
very low Fidelity compared to uh the
initial message that was sent out of the
source and and moreover there might also
be some uncertainty over these mutation
rates mu 1 not and mu zero one that
complicate this patient updating problem
okay and so what do we show in this
companion paper
we show that even with the sort of
unrealistic assumption that nodes know
exactly what the network looks like
um they have really really tight priors
over these mutation rates
um they they learn uh in a Bayesian way
it would turn it turns out that learning
fails as networks grow deep no matter
how broad they are
so even when you endow the learner with
all this information which it's going to
be unrealistic in in almost any real
situation you can think of
um
slight uncertainties over these mutation
rates mu 1 0 and mu zero one are going
to make it so that as networks grow deep
no matter how broad they are we won't be
able to overcome this this slight noise
and we won't be able to learn anything
in the limit
and so the nature of that result is then
to say that even if there's a
preponderance of communication about a
particular topic if people start out
with different beliefs then they're
going to get stuck at those beliefs
despite all of this communication happen
so we rationally don't update on the
basis of the information that they hear
um
this paper however we want to talk about
how uh the
we want to talk about how policy makers
can make interventions that actually
help the the learner so here we want to
in the companion paper we wanted to
prove an impossibility result here we
want to to prove a possibility result
and so we make what we think are more
realistic assumptions about the way
nodes are learning we assume that the
nodes uh the learner knows little to
nothing about the communication process
and uses really naive decision rules on
the basis of the messages that uh he or
she receives
and we want to ask the question what can
we do to help the learner succeed
and to this end we consider very simple
policy maker objectives that look like
this so policy maker is going to take
actions I'll describe what those actions
are to uh to achieve the following
objectives one could be to maximize the
probability that the number of true
messages uh the learner received exceeds
the number of false messages and you say
naive learning you mean I believe in one
if I see more ones that's you yeah
um another objective could be that I
want to ensure that the expected number
of true messages that are being sent out
on this network exceed the expected
number of false messages another natural
objective is to maximize the expected
number of true messages
and these sort of objectives reflect
agents when I equally choose actions
matching uh majority
so one way we can sort of uh microphone
this first objective is you can say that
agents
receive certain noise-up versions of
messages from their uh Information
Network and take the action that matches
the majority message
so if you're interested in that sorry
what did you call that naive I mean if
you don't know how deep they are
anything would it be any other
information I guess
um it could be naive in the sense that
uh if you know that people are more
likely to uh mutate messages in One
Direction
uh versus the other
that uh messages that are far away are
more likely to be of a certain type and
so you might disconnect
would have a different threshold
uh you might also start out with
different priors over what the states
are in antibiotics okay
um
right so so so this is this would be
maybe sort of one way to uh think about
the the uh
reason why you might be interested in
that first objective the agent might uh
take an action a that matches the true
state so make taken action one if if one
is a true State then if one is what what
she believes is a true statement and
zero otherwise and might get a payoff of
one if uh uh action is equal to the
state and and zero otherwise
and a way to sort of think about the
second objective is Maybe
you know I hear this sort of this
communication process run so the state
has realized I hear some ones and zeros
but I don't take an action just yet
tomorrow I hear more ones and zeros I
still don't take an action this process
repeats and after a long time I end up
taking uh an action one and zero so I
hear news about the president every day
uh but I only vote once every four years
and again if they so the agent is
choosing the majority action then the
policy maker might want to ensure that
the expected number of true messages
exceeds the expected number false
you average these quantities over the
notes in the networks it's a number of
messages the total number of messages
received by summed up for people
so here I'm fixing a learner and uh and
I'm looking for the expected number of
true versus false messages so you're
only optimize for the Wonder for the one
learner but then later I'm going to
think about homogeneous perhaps and so
the interpretations will be very similar
yeah
yeah
but if you think that people let's say
change message his own particles you may
say that if there is a more stringent
policy people try to engage
absolutely so so
um the way various policy interventions
are going to affect the incentives to
pass along information
um are going to be very important right
and we're abstracting away from all of
that not because those aren't important
but because we can think about a
thousand different reasons why people
might send us maybe I send something
because I'm trying to inform my friend
maybe I send something because I don't
know if it's true and I just wanted to
test it out and and put this message
maybe I just thought it was funny right
so
um I think empirically it's a question
why do people sort of share the messages
that they do and how should we model
incentives
um but holding fixed uh changes
endogenous changes in Behavior we were
interested here in sort of studying what
are the mechanical effects of these
interventions
what is the time Horizon when you talk
about number of messages
sorry
like when you ask for expected number of
true messages informed species we are
just looking at the limit for the time
Horizon
just taking an accent perspective so you
um right uh you're just uh you know what
these parameters are
okay so I'm going to now introduce a
little bit of terminology that will uh
crop up later when when I show you a
couple of propositions
um so for mutation rates mu 1 0 and mu
zero one I'm going to say that a set of
nodes in the information Network s
generate a generates a preponderance of
true messages if the expected number of
true messages exceeds the expected
number of false messages originating
from these sources in any uh state of
the world
so
um
once I fixed my set of nodes s in the
information Network I'm asking the
question you know let the communication
process run what is do I expect a
majority of these messages to be true or
do I expect a majority of them to people
um you're also fixing the learner fixing
the learner yeah so you fix the learner
and now you're fixing a set of nodes and
Learners uh uh Information Network
and then you're saying from the messages
that originate from these sources
by the time they trickle down to me do I
uh does the expected number of true
messages exceed the expected numbers
right and that's for a given pair of
mutation rates mu one zero and v01 we
can similarly Define things for a
compact set of mutation rates right a
policy maker might not know exactly uh
what are the rates with which things are
getting mutated and so they might want
to have a more robust objective and so
we say that s generates a robust
preponderance of true messages if the
expected number of true messages exceeds
the expected number of false messages
originating from these sources for any
state of the world and for any
realization of mutations
okay
finally I'll say that for a compact set
of a of mutation rates
the set s dominates S Prime
if for any pair of mutation rates in a
and in the mutation disfavored state
the expected number of true minus false
messages originating from s is weakly
greater than from S Prime and strictly
greater for for some pair of mutations
that's the state where so if zeros are
more likely to turn into ones then vice
versa then zero is the mutation dispute
okay so that's my setup and now I'm
going to uh think about what are neutral
policies that could reduce this
information
okay so here's just a numerical example
so here are the parameters that I have
this probability of transmission is is
set at 20 for each set of communication
um zeros mutated to ones three percent
of the time and one's mutated to zero is
ten percent of the time
foreign
and here we had a one message to start
and as it got passed along this chain uh
after three steps of transmission the
probability that that message uh is true
exceeds the probability that it's
dropped with a with a large problem
if we extend this
for a large T this is going to be small
most of the messages that we received
are going to be false
when the state of the world is formed
because one is a mutation that's famous
which is from being mostly true to
mostly false after seven steps of
transmission
so what that suggests is we should be
cutting the depth of these Networks
so that we improve the Fidelity of
messages that we're receiving and hear
more true than false things
um so uh if the true state is zero
there's no problem
because we're bound to hear a lot of
zeros anyways but if the true state is
one then the message uh messages that
travel too far are more likely to be
false
and it turns out that uh 7.5 is the
threshold uh Beyond which things start
to be mostly false rather than than true
um and so uh this is just thinking about
policies that cap distances that message
is trouble and proposition one does
exactly
so it says so there's some Expressions
up here
um you don't need to look at them just
yet
it says any given Source generates a
robust preponderance of true messages
and uh messages originating from The
Source are more likely to be true than
false for any pair of mutation rates
that you're considering if and only if
the distance uh from the learner to this
node is of no more than T star or t star
in some expression that I have up there
and then we give some interval such that
a depth cap is undominated if and only
if uh the depth cap Falls in that
interval
so caps outside of this interval
um are are not worthwhile because by
moving to a cap inside the interval you
can increase the expected number of true
minus false messages for any pair of
mutation rates
and this result follows just from the
formulas for the frequency ratios that
we got we want to make sure that the
probability that we're receiving more
true messages than false uh
the problem with the expected number of
true messages exceeds I expect a number
of false messages in any state of the
world
um and while the exact form of this uh
cap isn't important what is important is
that it's uh
so this is a typo what is important is
that it decreases in the asymmetry
between mutation bits
um so what's an intuition if zeros are
more likely to turn into ones
um then vice versa and these mutation
rates are really asymmetric it suggests
that we need to set tighter accounts
um than we would in a world where these
mutation rates were more balanced
between uh the the two directions
yeah yeah so the question is how do you
know whether you're in guides
you live in that kind of people so if
you have a platform you don't see the
content right hand check the truth
so how do you know the transition but
it's how can you perform yeah
yeah so that's a great question
um and the answer is that this is a sort
of the reason why we consider this
robust preponderance concept
um because you might have a lot of
uncertainty about those transition rates
right you might say zeros are more
likely to get exaggerated into ones or
vice versa but regardless of what I
conceive as being the possible
differences between these mutation rates
let me do something that's robust to all
those possible tests
and so you set a potentially really
tight cap if you have a lot of
uncertainty about what these uh mutation
rate asymmetries look like and maybe
even a stronger capitalists but that's
going to again depend on the basically
the asymmetry of these mutations that's
the object that's really going to drive
whether or not the capitalist move
subject
and also meet the fixing the asymmetry
the absolute level of noise
and and capping depth doesn't require
knowing
it we can implement this without
actually observing the things that are
being sent out all we're doing is we're
making sure that these messages travel
shorter distances so that the stuff that
we hear has a greater Fidelity to its
initial Source that's the idea
but the difficulty with a policy like
this is it's really hard to implement
because we don't really observe life
cycles of messages in a little bit of
context so when one of my uncles sends
me something on WhatsApp I don't know if
this was something uh that he heard from
someone directly a primary source or
this is something that he learned
through the grapevine right and because
I don't know these things it's you know
it's very hard for for me as a learner
to tell it's also hard for the platform
to tell the platform in an app like
WhatsApp can't even observe the messages
that are being sent even if you could
observe the messages on something like
Twitter you have to ask yourself is this
a new piece of information or is this a
mutated version of something that this
agent heard before right so following
life cycles of messages is very hard
and that leads us to think about uh
bread caps instead of death caps
so suppose the communication network is
an infinite tree
so nodes have on average an in-degree
and out degree of B
I consider a breath cap of D Prime less
than d
that means a node can pass to at most D
Prime of its neighbors and if it wants
to pass to more it can't and so it has
to randomly decide which D Prime it's
going to send a message to
and this is easy to implement as a cap
on message forwards and in fact it
platforms like WhatsApp do so they say
for example a given message can be only
forwarded to five other people
okay
so what does breath cap look like in
practice well suppose the probability of
passing messages is one and you have
some regular Network that looks like
this
once you impose the bread cap
a lot of these chains uh end up
disappearing so the reason is that the
nodes that aren't sending any
information to me anymore might have
chosen to send to other agents in uh
their Network
and so I don't I don't hear I don't hear
the the message that came came through
with these students
proposition two is an allow an analogous
result of proposition one but for bread
cups
it says that an infinite depth Network
generates a robust preponderance of true
messages if and only if its degree is
less than D Bar where D Bar is some
function that's given up here
and the depth cap D Prime is undominated
if and only if D Prime Falls in in a
certain interval
okay so again I'm going to tell you
about the comparative Statics of these
things so you don't have to look at
those those formulas
um so first let's think about why
breadth caps work
they work because the ratio of far nodes
to real to near nodes which uh you know
the ratio of things that are distance
Big T away versus Little T is given by
this expression here uh PD raised to the
power of Big T minus t when you impose a
cap this term is going down and so this
gives us what the one of the the two
punch lines of the paper which is that
caps on communication don't just reduce
the total amount of communication that's
happening they actually induce a
positive selection effect
whereby they increase the ratio of
messages that you hear nearby in the
network uh relative to those that are
far away
now next here's some sort of comparative
Statics so uh the Expressions if you
examine them will show that uh PD is
going to be less than one
um when these mutation rates are are not
equal
okay so that's kind of how you're
controlling things you want to make it
so that most of the messages that you
hear are nearby if PD were greater than
one you would be flooded with messages
that uh that appeared from uh that came
down from far away
moreover these caps D upper bar and D
are decreasing in the max mutation rate
increasing in these the minimum mutation
right so again we have this result that
the more asymmetric these mutation rates
are the tighter you would want to set
these cuts
and they're also decreasing in this
probability P of transmission
so if p is higher you're more likely to
hear stuff that originated really far
away and again you would want to set the
tire cup
and so this gives us our second punch
line which is that caps help not because
there's noise in communication but
because there might be some asymmetry in
this noise
if you had two things that were very
noisy you know they're they're noise up
to 40 percent of the time
you would still have that hearing more
messages is better than hearing fewer
messages because despite things being
noisy
the each message is each source is more
likely to give you a true message than
than not
yeah
um so this is a naive question but so
when you put a depth cap it's kind of
intuitive why you would reduce
misinformation because things are
getting corrupted as over time right yep
in this case you get a similar effect
just by doing breadth and I guess I'm
just asking is the intuition behind that
kind of just like uh your friends are
more popular than your phenomenon
because if you take this cap this ratio
when you have the time going to one is
it this is essentially equivalent to
that phenomena
um so is it equivalent to something like
the Friendship Paradox yeah
um so similar effect that's that's
giving you this good so my my intuition
from it is my intuition is that it's
basically making it so that once I'm in
close depth counts or sorry breadth
counts I have to make choices now about
which of my friends I'm going to send
the certain piece of information to it
means a good chunk of them are going to
miss out on it and that's happening in
every step of the way and so for people
who are farther away from me in the
network it's unlikely that through a
series of decisions that my message is
actually going to reach them cool and so
it's decreasing the uh distance that
distances that message traveled you're
not doing it in the first best way the
way you would with adapter because depth
cap your your new excise exactly the the
sources that you don't want right here
you're losing also some communication
from nodes that appear nearby on the
other hand it's going to be way more
feasible to do something like a red
technical
it helps
yeah but does it also mean that there's
just going to be very few messages left
in your information
uh there are going to be fewer messages
uh for sure so this both policies would
cut down on the quantity of
communication right
um there would be a sort of trade-off
between the number of messages that you
get and as a quality of the messages
that you get and so here we're only
looking at the objective of uh trying to
make sure that the the expected number
of true lines false messages for example
is excellent so the probability that you
hear a true message
a majority of true messages so so who
decides to ask true and what's not true
so that's the the idea the idea is that
there is something as a ground truth
right
um and you have agents who are taking
the action that correspond with the
majority of the messages that they hear
and you have a platform that's not
telling you that you know ones are more
likely or zeros are more likely and
selectively cutting down on them instead
the platform is simply
pruning the network by reducing its
depth if it can or more realistically
reducing the spread and doing that makes
it so that you're more likely to receive
a majority of true messages rather than
false ones because messages that you get
are from sources that are closer to you
in the network and therefore have a
greater Fidelity to the truth less
chance of getting noised up along the
way for their expenses
and so that's the sense in which we've
stated this is sort of a neutral or
information agnostic way of improving
the quality of information and proven
learning without actually taking a
stance on what's true of itself
is because maybe people close to me
who are getting the information from
sources that I know
I thought true that's true so so it
could be that if you have a bad luck of
the draw then you happen to be in a part
of the network where there are maybe
more deliberately biased yes right so
that could certainly happen exposed from
an ex-anti perspective
um as long as the messages that people
are hearing are more likely to be true
than false the initial signals
made from an extensions perspective the
probability of hearing measuring into
messages
so you said WhatsApp perhaps the number
of times you can forward
but it doesn't count the number of
messages that you've been sent
so in theory people could an alternative
version
so send one message
one the same message but I can send it
so like I could get any different
messages synthesize them in some way
and then I can send
my own version of the messages to many
people that's right so so
synthesizing isn't in this model but if
you did have just one agent sending uh
the same message to many people
um that would be uh
that would make it harder to learn
so you do want to so so so in practice
when you do set these caps doesn't mean
that literally now I can't talk uh share
this kind of information with more than
five friends just means sort of the
costs of doing so went up right I send
it and then I have to selectively send
pick some of my friends and do the same
but that's really at the end of the day
what we're trying to do we're trying to
increase the cost of sending the same
message to a lot of people
and so so that's that's a good message
it's a good message like if your account
from this information we want to
massively send that to as many people as
possible it's good information you want
to send it to more better
here uh we're doing a sort of
approach where we say look I don't know
what are the good messages and what are
the bad messages
but I know that I can clean up the
content that's being sent you know at
the expense of cutting down the amount
of content that you
can see by making sure that messages
don't travel too far and I can achieve
that through a question
you couldn't think about a policy where
I'm only allowed to send I can't send
the one and a zero and it's not allowed
um so then I will have to synthesize and
at some sense your model already
in some sense the the learner is doing
the learner is synthesizing right
and so perhaps you could
extend this model to allow for the
learner then think of the learner as
action intermediate who's going to send
the message corresponding to the
majority yep
um it seems possible to handle that I
want records
yeah so yeah we hadn't thought much
about that so one of our ideas in in
modeling the communication was to say
that you know in the sort of the group
models of other social learning Tech
models you you synthesize information
you form a posterior and you send that
and we were here trying to communicate
the idea that you know sometimes there's
just actual physical mutations in in
trying to interpret the things that we
we heard and we want to sort of capture
that kind of noise I think it's a very
reasonable thing to think about a sort
of hybrid model that says both that
physical messages can get mutated but
also agents selectively pick what it is
that they're going to send out from the
basis of the stuff that they heard so I
think that would be a very natural
impact some settings you can't send
contradictory signals
but but a policy like that would rely on
actually observing the message that's
being set up and that's one of the
things that we try to avoid so we want
to have a policy that actually doesn't
even rely on the messages that are being
sent does it require the policy maker to
know what speaks
okay
um so
these are just a picture so everything
that I showed you was in terms of uh
sort of maximizing the expected number
of true minus false messages it's more
intractable to work with uh probability
that majority messages are true uh
versus false but it turns out that these
policies at least in simulations
um uh end up doing very similar things
so here we have a policy of capping uh
the depth of trees for different levels
of breadth so the blue line is uh
represents a a trio breath five and the
x-axis is different different levels of
tree depth
and the y-axis is the probability that
the majority of signals received from
this information Network are true
um
and it seems that here that capping at
something like uh depth 6 or depth seven
is is is the uh right thing to do
um and notice that that answer doesn't
depend on the breadth of the tree nor
should it right because it's actually
the distance that individuals uh
messages travel that matters and and so
the the graph reflects that the policy
that we get from from maximizing the
expected number of true minus false
signals gives it gives a very similar
cap here
um notice also that if if the tree is
very broad then as the depth gets too
large
um then a majority of the signals are
going to be
um false right because the tree is
really Broad and a lot of the signals
are coming from far away rather than
nearby
there's a picture showing a similar
graph for for capping breath now the
lines represent a different mutation
probabilities the blue line is the
relevant one to compare to for the
parameters we've been talking about
um and again it seems that the cap that
we get from maximizing expected number
of true minus false messages is very
close to the cap required to maximize
the probability that most signals are
correct
but in order to be able to implement
these policies you do need to know
something about the probability right so
you you you need to have some guesses as
to how asymmetric these mutation rates
go and you might have a bunch of guesses
and you might not be able to pick which
of these guesses is true or you might
not even be able to express a prior over
uh these mutation rates and so the the
policy that we suggest says do something
that's robust to all of this
and set a potentially really
conservative type
so we here we get the policy for these
parameters we get a policy that says
that we should set a capital for around
4.6 and in in in WhatsApp for example
this capital is expired
okay so let's make some concluding
remarks
um
the model sort of highlights that uh
tagging and tracing messages will
enhance learning and so here we're going
uh through all these troubles because we
don't know how far messages traveled
before they reach us and so we don't
know how reliable they are
um and so understanding the value of
partially tagging uh messages
um you know could could improve things
and studying to the extent to what
extent it does uh I think is an
interesting Avenue for future work and I
think WhatsApp has introduced some
policies that try to do something like
this saying that certain types of
messages uh have been forwarded many
times before they reached you and so on
so sort of giving you some sense of of
what are messages that traveled far
um
here we have that xnt all these sort of
nodes are are the same
um one feature that many real world
networks uh uh exhibit is is homophily
and you might have homophilian mutation
times
so for example there might be friends
with a group of people who are more
likely to say that global warming is not
a big deal or more likely to say global
warming is a big deal and so whenever
you any information is passed related to
this topic you expect it to be
exaggerated more in one way than the
other
to some extent by thinking about a sort
of robust preponderance of true messages
we can uh partially account for this
right so there might be people
exaggerating things in one way or the
other but we're trying to have a policy
that's sort of robust to whatever the
mutation rate is but if you wanted to
think more carefully about optimizing uh
the way you set these caps then that's a
very different and uh and and harder
problem so for example
you might want to loosen caps so that
people are more likely to hear messages
that their immediate neighbors might not
send
um and so messages from farther away
trickle down that could potentially
counteract some of the misinformation uh
that agents are prone to hearing from
from their immediate neighbors and so
you would have to think about these
sorts of trade-offs
um another interesting Avenue for
research is to think about uh uh
platform incentives and how they might
diverge from regulator incentives and so
um I showed results for breadth cap
showing that if you just wanted to
ensure a robust preponderance of true
messages you would set a a breath cap of
D Bar which is going to be a lot looser
than the breath cap you would set if you
want to maximize the expected number of
true minus false messages and you can
write down decision problems where a uh
a platform might self-impose a cap like
dbar if it wants to ensure that people
actually visit the platform and aren't
blasted with false information but
conditional on that wants to maximize
the total amount of engagement on the
other hand a regulator who's not
actually interested in engagement is
more interested in whether or not agents
are solving their decision problem
correctly might set a cap of d-star and
so this suggests that there could be
this conflict between between policy
makers and and platforms and so you
there's a there's room for thinking
about what optimal regulation looks like
um and of course uh we sort of mentioned
that agents might have incentives to
communicate which interact uh with
setting these cups right if it happens
that uh
um you know people who generate false
messages are less likely to do so when
uh there is uh less chance of their
messages going viral then incentives
work in the direction of these caps but
you might also be able to tell stories
where people are actually sending true
messages are the ones who are more
discouraged from sending out these types
of messages and so incentives are going
to play a role uh to uh when you're
trying to consider it sort of the
cumulative effects of these sorts of
policies
um and while we study one sort of
setting uh I think it's important to ask
this question in other situations for
other kinds of platforms of what are
neutral policies that might enhance
learning but don't require the
implementer to actually take a stance on
what's true and false and don't require
the implementer to police content
people
more questions
[Music]
truthful messages being
that's right
and would it give the opposite
patients to think about someone trying
to feed the untreated yeah do you mind
repeating the questions so the question
was that this is a model in which
Source nodes are more likely to receive
exogenous true information uh than than
false information and that drives all of
the results
um so you want to shorten distances
between Source nodes and ultimate
receivers uh to improve the Fidelity of
the initial messages and improving
Fidelity is a worthwhile exercise if
what's initially being fed into the
network is more likely true pickles
um and certainly if if you were in a
situation where most of the information
that was being put in is false
information it would suggest that uh you
want to do something very different
but hopefully we're not in such a
pessimistic
but your model does work if sort of some
nodes some random subset of you know
actually leads
towards which side it's not that simple
yep as long as they're not in the
majority things will go through
um it could be an interesting question
to think about in networks where these
sort of malicious agents try to locate
themselves
um and that might have some implications
for how to think about some of those
things so what the effectiveness of
cooperation
but we see these malicious agents as
randomly appear in different parts of
the networks in such a way it's a
majority of messages that are passed
from extended perspective we're still
going to be true
if this time no no please
so suppose you have different groups
some groups are being had troops some
groups are being
and then shortening the cat figures is
going to increase polarization here
potentially that's a very good point
yeah uh so in in homophilus networks
shortening caps would create more
polarization it creates this sort of
echo Chambers basically we're you're
hearing messages mostly of certain types
and in terms of the policy I guess you'd
want to think about implementing it
so if polarization is not directly in a
targeting and reducing polarization is
not directly an objective policy maker
that's saying I know some agents are
more prone to exaggerated messages in
One Direction I know other agents are
more prone to exaggerating it in the
other and that there's some awfully so
the agents around them have similar
behaviors
um then you say let's just throw these
pairs of mutation rates into our set a
and let's set a cap that's sort of
robust today
but uh if we were thinking about
polarization then we might want to
loosen these caps so that messages from
far away which are likely to be
different sort of filter into our uh
local information Networks
let's keep
okay that's thanks so much again
um so we were discussing at lunch how
important
summarize to the outside world what
we're doing at this Workshop because
it's not interested in case of people
who study epidemics and people who study
information strengths some from an
incentive perspective and then two
initiatives we have there we invite
everybody
if you actually would like to know how
much people to want
one is we want to write maybe a paper
which says
given that they have passed the epidemic
uh what did we learn we don't really
want to fight policy effects so we don't
want to write okay you should do x y z
but more in the sense okay for the next
epidemic maybe we should have modesters
take into account if people only want to
Source distance for a certain time then
what you just or what kind of models
should we have which may be taken into
account
degree in homogeneities or what kind of
models we should have to bring in
social aspects things like that so sort
of okay after this pandemic we're at the
beginning model it's really impaired us
much more than they do the flu season we
don't want to say to people okay if you
have only distances on day one everybody
would be answered today
that we want to write a paper what has
the community learned what would be
useful for the scientific Community to
have or think about before the next
epidemic the few of us at lunch they're
interested in that but we wanted by
everyone who sings so if you have a new
Mass serum
so the second one is more the Ascension
of maybe just having rather
the volume it could be on the Internet
or it could actually
the actual summary of talks
interesting because
can write a million offset but they're
not that many conferences between
together these audiences so this would
be a Centric to the speakers if you gave
a talk would you be interested in
writing a one-page abstract or an
airtime pages
and we look
how many of you want to do that there
are only three of you that we probably
just cancel it if people mainly want to
do for abstracts it's a different thing
as people say okay we would like to
contribute
something so please write to me about
those subjects write to me sising
Elizabeth
um about if you are interested just let
us know we'll also announce that
tomorrow morning yes and in any case
please don't disappear because Anna is
going to give a touch yes in 30 minutes
yeah thank you
okay